verizon just sold
aol and yahoo for five billion dollars
and a new company will be known as
yahoo going forward a business insider
story after just over five years of
ownership ryzen has sold this
ownership stake in yahoo nao for 5
billion the telecom giant announced on
monday morning the new company formed by
aol and yahoo will be known solely as
yahoo and the new company owner
his private equity firm apollo global
management marquee media groups
being purchased in the deal include inga
jet
tech crunch yahoo finance other notable
products and the sale also include aol
dial up internet customer base yahoo
mail and yahoo portal homepage
verizon originally purchased ao back in
may of 2015 for 4.4 billion
and yahoo in july for 4.83
billion dollars making the sale of both
companies for 5 billion about a 50
overall loss thoughts quite a haircut
yes it is a huge haircut and apollo
still might be overpaying
i mean did you see part of the deal is
the aol dial up yeah
oh my gosh so guys we got this dial up
hang on isn't it like 1.5 million people
that are still paying like 24 dollars a
month
yeah it i mean there is aol dialogue
because they forgot to cancel
uh or something my understanding is it's
24 to 26 million dollars a month that's
sitting in there
folks if you're a quarter billion
dollars for that you may want to go take
a look at your credit card bill
you may still be paying 24.95 from 20
years ago it just shows how
the world has changed so quickly you're
talking about aol and yahoo were they
not the two biggest internet providers
yes yeah
in the year 2000 i mean i still got my
aol account that i'll give to somebody
if i don't want that they were
disruptive spamming my email
is a network provider and yahoo had
partnered with the um
the rbox like sbc and they were
providing so spc was providing you know
the dsl early dsl to your
home what happened here this
is the fallacy of expanded product
what happened is verizon went out and
bought a bunch of media assets that they
thought were going to pump through
phones and do things like that
i remember verizon tried to build a
thing called vcast as its own
network a tv network that would be on
your phone with all this interesting
content and everything and they were
going to be
you know they were going to be the cable
system on your phone and what they
failed to understand is they were a
platform
uh the mobile platform was a platform
and you had media out there already you
just had to figure out how to get the
media on it make a buck on it
apple figured out 30 please for the
we're the platform with the phone we're
going to make stuff no
everybody else will make stuff but we'll
take 30 of everything that comes through
the tollbooth
that's what verizon should have done
that's what sprints should have done
they were fools and so they went out and
bought all this remember huffington post
was part of this
yes it was they were they were spun out
of this yep and they got a guy named tim
armstrong who came here and they
rebranded the whole thing
oath i think it was oath you know as i
recall
and they're going to do this it's going
to be different and tim armstrong also
said oh by the way we're going to do
something else with um
with aol we're going to have citizen
journalism he had a name for it remember
it was always going to be citizen
journalism that
gives you local stories that are very
interesting and everything i already
have that it's called twitter i just
hashtag dallas i have all kinds of
citizen journalists up there
um and so this is just the fallacy of
this
i what's really funny about this is
when gopro hired people i believe it was
from hbo
and they said hey we're going to make
the we're going to make the gopro media
network and we're going to do our own
media and everything
why do you have to do that you sold
millions and millions of these cameras
all your
customers are making all the media you
curate it and offer it you're not the
media company
but there is a fantasy about being the
content creator content provider
that gopro and verizon had and it was
this is just a remarkably bad idea
and i happen to agree when i look at
this and i put it through
my thought in terms of private equity i
don't think i don't think yahoo
i don't think these two companies worth
two billion dollars and i think
set your clock apollo is going to dish
this off to somebody and it's going to
mark down again
because it's a five billion dollar
write-off for um verizon
so if you want to buy verizon you've got
uh potential some losses
yeah discount i just i just took a deep
dive into private equity um
for my weekly and private equity sitting
on 1.6
trillion dollars of dry powder and they
can't find targets which is the same
problems
they have nothing to buy and i mean if
you look at the post pandemic there was
like five minutes where they could buy
distressed companies
and then jay powell came into the
bailout so their window for buying
distressed
closed quickly so now they're paying i'm
going to be missed my warren buffett
moment they're paying 11.4 times ebitda
we've never seen multiples like this in
private equity
but they can't they have to get rid of
the money they have i mean and and
public pensions
we talk about that the money yeah by the
way do you know what was the maximum
problem too do you know what's the
highest aol was valued at one point
market cap highest ever you know what ao
was hiding some guesses i like guesses
what do we got what do you think if
you're listening to this give me aol and
give me yahoo what was yahoo worth the
most at one point what was aol worth the
most at one point
highest ever market cap circa 2000.
what's the number what do you think i i
don't recall but just throw a number up
probably 250 billion combined
250 billion or combined no i was going
to aol is 250 billion and yahoo's what
same i mean microsoft just crossed two
trillion right so
what are you going to say a while ago by
the way this is five billion dollars
they bought both of them for so just
keep this part in mind
maybe a hundred billion i'm saying aol
but yeah
mark down you can follow the aol
markdown game starting with um aol time
order bought my time award i think
ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding
ding ding ding ao was a 200 company
and yahoo was a 100 billion dollar
company max do you know 100 billion
the moment where you saw yahoo kind of
go in a bad direction
you kind of went in that direction is
when they bought
broadcast if you remember when they
bought broadcast from our cube and they
bought broadcast from mark cuban on
april 1st 99 you know for how much
5.6 billion dollars they bought
broadcast for 5.6 billion
which was a mark cuban company more
than aol and aol and yahoo today
which when that company sold in that
time three years later they shut the
company down i think 30 percent of the
shares uh cuban owned 17
was a wagner's shares and from that
point on yeah i was like wait a minute
what just happened here we just bought a
company we wrote it off three years
later
the check went over there because one
year you know the company grew 250
when they went public so market wanted
it they got it and also at the same time
if you read ted turner's book and you
follow his
uh history when did his demise come
when did this fall come is when he went
and
did business with the time warner aol
that whole
merger that took place looking back he
lost control when he was leading
everything was good the moment he had no
longer had voice he no longer had any
influence so
there are certain dealings you know you
do certain acquisitions certain things
work out good certain things don't
and we're running a record record run
right yeah
these last two months excuse me speaking
of expensive celebrity divorces
which one is ted turner yeah well yeah
that's another one wow
well the um uh two two points here
warren buffett said in his
latest annual meeting do you know what
percentage of companies that were the
top 20 companies
in the world are still in in 1995 are
still in the top 20. oh this is the s p
migration over time yeah do you know how
many zero
zero so like all these companies that
were just gangsters back in 2000
are nothing now and then that's why we
have we
we need to home grow our scientists and
mathematicians
because we need to come up with whatever
the next generation is going to be
if adam has it his way it's not going to
happen it's happening we're going to
space me and my cats are going to space
what's funny is i remember being like
this was probably in early 2000s i was
senior in college and i remember asking
friends
um all right who do you use as your
search engine because i was still using
yahoo
and there was like 10 people in the room
and everyone used google and i was like
what do you mean yeah
guys they're like nah i don't think
about that yet and one engineer said
lycos
yeah and so they were all moving to
google and i was still on yahoo so that
means that at some point you're going to
understand the space race
thing one of these days you just got to
play catch up 100
of people were interested in 1960. hang
on 20 percent of people you think 100
how do you know 100 were interested i
was in high school then i remember
i'm an old soul did you hear she just
did by the way your lip is bleeding she
hit you pretty good there
okay i can take it someday you'll
understand the space adam actually can't
take it so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
you